welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Rick and
Morty season 7 episode 5 UNM ricken a
title that's a play on Unforgiven the
1992 Western directed by and starring
Clint Eastwood it's a story that Dem
mythologizes the Western genre by
frightening you with a supposedly white-
hat hero who goes completely Savage to
prove that the genre you're watching is
not what you think it is similarly this
episode of Rick and Morty demystifies
the series by closing out Rick's
lifelong pursuit of Rick Prime in bloody
bloody fashion and revealing the origin
of evil Morty it's packed with Easter
eggs animation details and nods to the
past episodes so let's break down this
Canon episode baby we open on the Smith
house but there's no crack around the
entire perimeter of the ground so we
know we are in a different Universe in
c137 because of season one Rick C
Business episode which was by the way
the last time and the first time we saw
slow Mobius that episode teleported the
house during the party leaving that
crack around it for all Cannon episodes
thereafter the yellow Sunset Sky casts
everything in the golden yellow tones
that we have previously associated with
the evil Mor character his portal is
yellow not green Morty is so annoyed at
having to go back up yet another asra
crystals and this time Rick snapping at
him to stop threatening to quit Just
Hits differently with Morty sorry to be
such a high maintenance Morty why don't
I get you a drink inside that fridge is
a container reading do not open until X
and Morty gives Rick a six-pack of Foy
beer suggesting that only an evil Morty
would enable Rick's alcoholism in his
bedroom this Morty sutters a new device
later revealed to be his evil Morty ey
patch drunk Rick goes on the rant that
he ended the first episode with Rick and
Morty forever and forever 100 years Rick
and Morty things Rick Rick and Morty 100
years forever yeah pal Rick and Morty
100 years forever whereas Rick
previously scared this Morty by standing
over him with his face in Shadow the
garage lights behind his head now evil
Morty assumes this pose over Rick a way
to symbolize their shifting of positions
in this reality their shifting statuses
evil Morty enters with the scarm mouthed
evil Rick from season 1's close Rec
counters the one revealed to be a remote
controlled puppet by evil Morty in that
episode this Morty registration office
has brochures a jeez the perfect fit and
it's in the month of mortim the clerk
says an IP patch you know how we feel
about Pirates yes a call back to the
pirates of the pancreas ride that Rick
found to be scary in season 1 and the
joke in the season 3 finale stand down
he's not afraid of pirates R Morty that
part was true so as we all expected evil
Morty's eye patch was also designed to
be a pirate fear tactic this puppeted
evil Rick kills the other Rick guard his
back bending backwards revealing himself
to be the puppeted corpse of the evil
Morty Rick as evil Morty removes his own
records from the Morty archives and the
two go on a killing spree in a prince
themed reality they stab the scientist
formerly known as Rick who is mentioned
having been found dead in that close
Rick counters episode everyone in this
family wears Prince attire the room has
purple wallpaper with a paisley design
on it there's also a Little Red Corvette
in a photo and the dog Snuffles is
dressed as Prince as well they're eating
spaghetti and one wonders if that is
actually the guts of this reality's 41
Kepler B Planet then they go to a
turtleneck reality where Snuffles also
wears a total neck in the photo this is
one of the thousands of Morty that evil
Morty kidnapped to torture to hide from
The Citadel by poking them in the sides
evil Morty scans each of their Ricks
then we catch up with the events of
close Rick counters with arm Morty freed
all those tortured mores to swarm that
evil Rick and we see one of the Council
of Ricks Rick toin Sanchez toin takes
pity on evil Morty and escorts him away
with his cloak evil Morty wanders into
the Citadel slums known as Morty town
and he reads the paper about the
upcoming election graffiti on the walls
shows M plus J for Morty plus Jessica
then we CCH up with the events of season
3 episode8 The Rick lantis mixup with
the president Morty and the election
storyline and his takeover of the
Citadel and then we catch back up with
the events of season 5 episode 10 Rick
maray Jack with the return of evil Morty
and his escape from the central finite
curve and his little hop through his
yellow portal which is the last we had
heard of him until season 6's solar
Rick's episode that established that
evil Morty's plan included destroying
Rick's portal gun travel so now evil
Morty is running through a reality mass
that looks like broken pieces of other
realities and surfaces that we've seen
throughout the series all merged into
this one Bridge the episode calls this
the infinite we see multiversal
Travelers opening portals of all shapes
and colors each of them presumably Rick
style scientists who figured out their
own portal gun travel and just ended up
here one portal drops out a family in
the style of the Jetson this first
family wearing white red and gold who
get immediately shredded by their
variants in blue and yellow and they get
shredded by their variant in orange and
green and I like how each of their
outfits match the color of the portal
that they drop through but this last
family gets eaten by a double-headed
Crystal monster which evil Morty flees
until the monster is shredded by evil
razor net so that he can retrieve this
pink Crystal so essentially evil Morty
found a better way to retrieve these
crystals that his Rick made him go up
and ass to get in the opening scene even
Morty flies past other interdimensional
beasts and these unlucky scientists of
various species and he identifies one
sphere in the central finite curve where
he uses that pink Crystal to add one
extra layer of shielding to his mansion
that allow him to kind of block out the
view of the infinite and give himself a
nice golden atmosphere like the reality
he left but then evil Morty realizes
that the cause of this disruption to his
paradise has been our Rick from this
season searching the central finite
curve for Rick prime using this battle
station to run these tubes into multiple
realities and Frack them down Morty and
Rick plug what are essentially large
Duracell batteries into the machine with
positive and negative ends and listen
closely to when Morty recharges one of
them it's just good to see you outside
the sub basement yeah they included the
sound effect an iOS device makes when
you plug the charger in Rick is Flushing
out all of Rick Prime's decoys we know
from the season 5 episode multiplicity
that Ricks create almost infinite decoys
of themselves that in turn create more
decoys themselves so it's no surprise
that Rick Prime does this too and then
evil Morty shows up shouldn't you be
turning yourself into a pickle yeah of
course they not to the pickle Rick
episode but also a dig at Rick's past
refusal to go to therapy but Rick says
he didn't expect to interfere with evil
Morty shock waves have more range than I
thought Jesus you heard a compliments a
monkey humping a shotgun has more range
than he thought yeah I just like the
continuity detail that normally the most
hard-hitting jokes are given to Rick but
in the case of evil Morty they really
Sav the meanest ones for him I like how
our Morty is running off to find a net
for evil Morty the idea being that
either something as simple as a net is
really the only way to catch any Morty
or this just something Rick might have
told AR Morty to get him to leave them
alone or maybe a false story because he
wanted Morty to think that he could just
catch evil Morty with a nonviolent
method but evil Morty um actually Rick
to filter for probability stasis but the
Rick Prime that gets caught is actually
a trap that explodes into black goo
trapping them in a box with other Ricks
who had tried to track down Rick Prime
as well these include a nerdy Rick a007
Rick a rick with a heart locket a John
mlan Rick wearing an undershirt and no
shoes just like Bruce Willis and die
hard and then finally a scraggly looking
Rick who's crouching in the corner kind
of looks like memory Rick from his
earlier years whom we saw in the season
5 finale when he was first journeying
out to avenge Dian and find Rick Prime
by the way that younger memory Rick was
the one that was trapped in the
subconscious in the post-credit Montage
of episode two of this season I think
this guy's a different Rick though he
has been there the longest and he says
he's knocked off three clones then an
Indiana Jones Rick drops in firing a gun
to which the bullet only stops when it
hits evil Morty Shield showing its
energy absorbing power compared to any
of the technology of the walls of this
box that Rick Prime could make then a
pre-recorded Rick Prime message plays
and drops each of them down a shoot with
levers that automatically sort them two
by two in different boxes and Rick Prime
reveals that all of the Dian were erased
from all existences using a device
called the Omega device the Omega device
by the way is also the name of a super
weapon from Futurama that popped up in
the episode into the wild green Yonder
in the duels our Rick beats Die Hard
Rick by deflecting his blasters with his
shield automatically alter Rick
completely wrecks the nerdy Rick and
then Indiana Jones Rick shoots and kills
007 Rick Rick tells evil Morty that he
should help them because they both hate
Rick Prime since he's the worst Rick but
evil Morty responds the worst turd is a
pizza wa tough customer how how is the
worst turd a pizza I did have to kind of
pause on this one but he is saying that
since the worst Rick is technically the
most unlike the other Ricks then evil
Morty might like him like kind of the
worst thing at being a turd would be
something that you would love to eat ah
co-pro fasia on Rick and Morty making
another comeback so scraggly Rick
electrocutes Indiana Jones Rick who
Withers into dust and dies reminding us
of the death of Walter Donovan in Last
Crusade but the door opens to scraggly
Rick and no surprise Rick and evil Morty
work great together throughout this
episode like here Rick bisects his top
half evil Morty kicks it it's kind of
creepy how well they work together Rick
Prime drops in a Diana death robot you
sucked at eating P clearly just said to
be hurtful but I also won't deny it I
was young Rick has to destroy this robot
and then the Box Goes Up in Flames what
do you think sub their barrier blocking
the portal fluid can't be that mine will
get through it yeah it kind of gets
buried there but evil Morty apparently
designed a better port gun than Rick's
was Rick merges the two guns and then
Powers it with some of the black goo
that he had harvested and the portal
that gets projected swirls with Rick's
green evil Mor's gold and Rick Prime's
black all swirled in together oh one
shot energy huh I think I'll try
[Applause]
it so what does one shot's Focus shoe
do
[Music]
eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order Rick uses this goo to locate
Rick Prime in heads out going to kill my
Nemesis I can't help but feel a little
sad for Mr Nimbus who has been
officially replaced as Rick's primary
Nemesis evil Morty suggests that once
Rick kills his Nemesis he might kill
himself next this is something that has
been hinted at throughout the series but
in the last episode we saw that Rick had
actually built a suicide chamber and had
been keeping it a secret this whole time
evil Morty and Morty portal over to help
Rick whether he wants it or not so Rick
charges to Rick Prime's Fortress which
are surrounded by the same killbots that
he Unleashed on them back in season 6
episode 10 rical Mor punon Rick morc and
in solar Ricks Rick says he built it
again can of course referring to Rick
Prime's Death Star like base the Death
Star that was rebuilt in Return of the
Jedi now Rick Prime calls R Rick a wife
guy which you know it's kind of a social
media thing where dudes make a constant
post about how much they love their
wives in order to get likes it kind of
sounds like Jerry is the ultimate wife
guy of Rick and Morty Rick Prime says
that they are the only two Ricks who
actually invented portal travel and he
pulls out Rick's smash car I can see why
you hate him and she sounds like our
wife like like in AED up robot way but
that's definitely her voice ah so the
solar Ricks episode showed us Rick's
Diane AI which was voiced by Carrie
Walgren who also voices Rick's car on
this series and his computer hinting
that Rick designed it this way
intentionally and now Rick Prime
confirms it rick Prime has updated the
Omega device so that it can be fired
multiple times and he plans to erase the
entire Smith family person by person so
Rick Prime releases some decoys and even
Morty deploys some very do o looking
tentacles that shoot some bombs but Rick
Prime starts by a member of Rick's
family who's technically his uncle slow
Mobius we first met him in the season 1
episode Ricky business Rex where's my
wife I was just with my wife Uncle slow
slow Mobius yeah this one hurts me too
and we see all the alternate timeline
slow Mobius is a baseball player a Rodeo
Cowboy a king who has hunted a bear a
family man a two-dimensional art
rendition and an evil squirrel and mobus
is dropped into the Omega device and he
slows down time before he
dies afterward Morty rightfully points
out how of the worst possible time to
use his powers just made the death
happen slower and then we see how slowmo
was erased from his family and they all
react to his eraser the art rition
erases into specific shapes the bull
reacts to having no one writing him
anymore Rick fires a bunch of bullets at
Rick Prime who stops them like Neo in
The Matrix and then he loads them into
another gun and fires back Rick bends
Rick Prime's Blaster Barrel back at him
but Rick Prime can regenerate his flesh
evam Morty helps out and again they work
great together he does spin kicks to
allow Rick to reset for another spin
kick Rick fires a rocket like one that
Tony Stark would fire out of his armor
Rick Prime catches it and throws it back
at him Rick Prime snaps his fingers
revealing three giant robot Dian arck
dazed hits a button on his leg right
before he knows robot Diane is going to
punch him this keeps his leg activated
to keep inching him forward evil Morty
scans Rick Prime to see his upcoming
attacks seeing knife and then rist gun
and then guat Rick guat is the mutant
twin that grows out of George from Total
Recall Rick's unconscious body is slung
around by his own cybernetic leg which
nunchucks him around until Rick Prime
rips off that leg and the Rick rips off
his arm to plug into his leg stump Rick
Prime does the same with Rick's leg and
I just love how reverse compatible all
of their cybernetic parts are their arms
and legs get conjoined and Rick uses his
flame wrist Rick Prime uses his chainsaw
tongue guat Rick pops out and stabs Rick
in the belly Rick Prime remains standing
and greets who he thinks is his original
grandson oh uh original grandson oh jeez
nice to meet you I guess I like how Eva
Morty really plays up the uncertainty
more than our Morty normally emotes like
he's a full sociopath arm Morty wakes up
why am I wearing an eye patch did we
switch shirt s yeah thanks for the
assist yeah I like the attention to
detail in case anyone was also using the
torn shirt sleeve to tell them apart
evil Morty fries Rick Prime's backup so
if he dies he would be dead for good he
offers all right never been a sidekick
guy but I'm starting to see the value
you want a job we could be like Batman
and Robin h i don't need a robin again
the best burns are reserved for evil
Morty evil Morty's tablet lists Rick
Prime schematics as booger AIDS V2 which
is a call back to solar Ricks and
Morty's mind blowers in which Rick hates
to name things and he names everything
is booger AIDS Eva Morty reanimates our
Rick telling him knock yourself out yeah
it's a great turn of for AIDS because
yeah he's literally telling the old man
exactly what to do here so Rick savagely
beats Rick Prime to death with his fists
it's very telling that he doesn't use
any of the many many many killing
implements that he's developed over the
years maybe because he's depleted all of
them but maybe because he just wants to
make sure he's actually doing it the
oldfashioned way like he's been waiting
for this and he does it in the most
feral way possible Rick Prime screams at
him you would have been
me I just walked into your garage before
you walked into mine yeah it's one final
taunt because Rick Prime is in effect
saying you're not killing me the worst
of me is going to live on in you now
evil Morty asks Rick how's it feel
better no exactly the same yeah it
always does yeah it's kind of been the
theme Revisited in countless revenge
stories like when someone gets revenge
that they've been seeking does it heal
them in most cases no now we don't see
Rick Prime get buried or anything and
people might question if he's actually
dead but he is dead it's done in a
Variety article co-creator Dan Harmon
and writer Scott martyr talk about Rick
Prime being dead and all the Thematic
doors that now opens up for the series
Dan Harman said I think there's still a
conclusion to a story here because the
narcissist will tell you that destroying
yourself it doesn't solve a problem how
Rick reacts to losing his sense of
purpose gives the Rick and Morty team
plenty to work with throughout the rest
of the season Scott martyr said what do
you do if you're Braveheart and you've
been avenging your dead wife and you
succeed and don't die and then live
beyond it where's your story go when
that's all that's to find you so after
destroying the core of the Omega device
evil Morty says I can end the Rick
experiment anytime I want why threaten
why not just do it because using a
weapon like this doesn't get you left
alone you are a little different though
Rick maybe I can use that someday yeah
Morty Cycles back to Rick to the
alternate Rick at the beginning of this
episode telling this evil Morty to stop
threatening and just do it but this time
evil Morty pulls the punch so over the
final minutes we hear Mazy stars look
down from the bridge look down from the
bridge this is the same music that
played at the end of season 1 episode 6
is Rick Potion Number Nine and Rick is
totally back to uh the same kind of
mental place he shuts down the layer
that he was using to hunt Rick Prime the
lyric everybody seems so far away from
me plays as Rick watches Beth and space
Beth and Jerry washed in the car and
then the family eats breakfast as Rick
cracks some joke about Jerry that
everyone laughs at but we don't hear it
instead Rick just kind of laughs to
himself eats some eggs smiling but is
brought back to his senses by The Taste
or rather tastelessness of food his
smile Fades and his thousand yard stare
returns just like the one he had at the
end of Rick Potion Number n where does
Rick go from here the post-edit scene
sequence takes us to the wife of slow
Mobius their kids don't even remember
their father so she spirals into
alcoholism The Hourglass is turned on
inside because she doesn't care about
time but her head and her belly clocks
spin hour by hour day by day we see her
tattooing on her Knuckles never slow yes
it's beat for beat a recreation of Rick
spiral from Rick marai Jack after he
lost Diane like we see her building her
own space cruiser but this one is time
themed she scans be after Bean with a
scanner that is in the shape of a clock
and then we see here eating Ramen at the
futuristic bar like we memory Rick doing
both of these in homage to another
Philip K deck adaptation Blade Runner
but unlike Rick she moves on she meets a
new partner and they fall in love and
move in with each other we see photos
and from the plane kids they ship on a
clock shaped rug in front of a clock
shaped window we see how this guy is a
widower with a kid of his own and the
families have now merged yet they keep
on their shelf a photo of slow Mobius
beside this new guy's late wife also I
love how you can see one of the photos
they visited the seoa national park it
looks like the giant Sherman tree it's
so sweet but I also just love that we
see the the consequences of everything
on this show and this kind of gives us
some hope hopefully for Rick's ability
to just move on from this someday hey
please support us with our OB from Loki
inspired shirt we're all going to die
you know Rick would love to wear one of
these grab one of these at nerd ride.
shop you can follow me on all social
platforms at eaos subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye
la